3 years of drought have forced more than
a million people from their homes in
Somalia many of them into camps like
this one in the capital Mishu now their
shelters are being washed away by floods
after days of torrential
rains it's raining for a fifth day our
makeshift shelters were washed away
children are missing now we don't know
whether they're dead or alive we request
the aid agencies to urgently help us
most of the people people in the camps
were herders until the pastures became
too dry and more than a million
livestock died of thirst others were
farmers who could no longer grow crops
now SES are the countrysider
underwater the un's Intercontinental
panel on climate change or ipcc says the
Horn of Africa is one of the places in
the world that's most vulnerable to the
effects of climate change there is quite
a big irony around people fleeing for uh
the the fact that they don't have water
and now fleeing because they have too
much water and so it's a real uh
dichotomy or problem that we're seeing
and the ipcc report quite clearly says
that this cycle of flooding and drought
is going to continue and we're going to
see this more and more unless we really
do something on a global scale to try to
reduce these uh and try to stay on this
Paris 1.5 alignment Decades of armed
conflict as well as increased food
prices exacerbate by Russia's invasion
of Ukraine have made the crisis worse
the UN says more than 40,000 people died
last year because of the drought about
half of them children these floods are
now killing even more Malcolm Webb Al
jazer